Hi. My name is Andy Brown.
This hex semester I’m going to be teaching an Introductory Physics Course called Landmarks In Physics.
This class is going to use some of the major discoveries in physics
as a way to teach you the important concepts of physics.
I’m going to be traveling throughout Europe
to some of the places where these important discoveries were made.
On each location, we’re going to interview experts,
talk to some physicists and figure out how this problem had been solved
and over the course of the unit we’re going to solve it ourselves.
Now, don’t worry if you don’t have any experience in physics
as long as you have a basic idea of algebra, you’re going to succeed.
By the end of this course, you’re going to know the basics of data analysis,
uncertainty in measurement and how to design an experiment,
and of course, some of the important concepts in physics;
for example, the conservation of energy.
See you in class.